hello everyone and welcome to a
spectacular game from round nine of the
Shah Bundesliga it's a game between
Alexander ingeichen the Michael Adams
and it's something that you would expect
from Rubenstein perhaps in 1907 but
definitely not another final position
you would expect in 2023 so uh without
further Ado let's check it out Alexander
with the white pieces opens with Ponte
C4 he goes for the English opening uh we
have E5 by Michael Knight to F3 going
for the nimsovich variation Knight to C6
with G3 Knight to F6 Bishop to G2 and
Bishop to C5 now going for very rapid
development here uh castles we have D6
Ponte E3 and Adams also castles that's
not a castles like I said Adam's castles
and there are a couple of moves that
read this possession D4 is exclusive
almost exclusive plate here there is a
game where D3 was played also A3 is a
known move but here we have Knight to C3
and it is now already as of move 7 that
we have a completely new game so Pawn to
A6 we have uh Pawn to D4 now striking in
the center Bishop to A7 and now Pawn to
H3 stopping Bishop to G4 so Rook to B8
preparing B5 uh and now Pawn to A4
stopping that with Bishop to F5 uh and
now Knight to H4 challenging the bishop
here and if you go back Bishop to G6
that's not really great uh White will
just trade and play D5 and it's not the
the greatest of possessions for black
for example Knight E7 and pawn to B4 and
white is very very happy with his Queen
side expansion uh this will be a very
very hard hard game for black to play so
instead Bishop back to D7 we have Pawn
to D5 uh Knight to E7 and now King to H2
uh and here Bishop to C5 Michael shows
just how uh how strong he is and how
important it is to prevent white from
playing Pawn to B4 we all need to learn
something from Michael here so here Rook
to B1 uh preparing this Pawn to be four
and A5 stopping it we have pawned the E4
and now uh the situation in the center
is pretty close there you don't have to
worry about B for white will at some
point play Pawn to F4 uh but now it's
your turn to challenge the center and
you will do that by playing Pawn to C6
we have Pawn to F4 Knights the G6 now
challenging the Knight on H4 and here
okay you either trade or go back with
Knight to F3 uh but uh here uh engage
plays F captures on E5 we have Knight
captures on E5 this is now an excellent
Square for this Knight Pawn to B3 and
now Ponte H6 we have Knight to E2 and
now Rook the E8 not rushing everything
that uh there are still a couple of
pieces that need to be developed uh with
Bishop to B2 getting the bishop to this
beautiful diagonal and now a c captures
on D5 only now you capture once you've
put every piece on optimal square e
captures and D5 and only now Knight to
H5 and okay luckily white does not have
any Discovery so you don't have to worry
here uh Knight to F3 we have Knight
captures on F3 with check Rook captures
and now the queen comes into the game
Queen to G5 with Queen to F1 putting
pressure on that F7 pawn and Rook the E7
uh Michael just defends here we have
Pawn to G for attacking the Knight and
now it would be uh it would be playing
right into White's hands if you go back
with Knight to F6 if you go back Knight
to F6 then white happily sacrifices uh
The Exchange here you do not want to
capture because then Bishop captures on
F6 attacks the queen and the Rook you
you will want to play Rook captures on
E2 Queen characters on E2 and only now G
captures and F6 where you have this uh
weird position where Black's King side
is uh ruined but okay white king said
isn't spectacular or either and it's
still a game why it should be maybe a
little bit better but nothing
spectacular however Rook beat the E8 by
Michael and this is now very very hard
to play for black it's uh almost
impossible to find the move uh one move
you don't want to do is Knight the G1
but it's exactly the move you have to
make in order to try and survive the
game it was not played in the game I
will just show quickly what happens the
problem is now Bishop captures and G4
happens and after captures captures it
it will be well almost wishful thinking
to survive this attack with the bishop
the two Rooks the Knight and queen
surrounding the white king maybe it's
possible uh who knows however after
rugby the e8g captures and H5 was played
and now look at this Rook captures on E2
and now Rook the G3 challenging the the
black queen also defending on G2 also uh
once you move Rook captures and G7 will
happen so there are many ways for whites
to win the game here but there is one
that pretty much forces resignation on
the spot so feel free to pause the video
and win the game for Adams while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that of
course the queen shall not move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook 8 to E3 and I almost
wanted to say it was in this position
that um industry signed the game but he
didn't he should have but uh he he still
continued for for a few more moves or
rather maybe two moves uh because uh if
you capture the queen then look at this
Rook captures on H3 is Checkmate the the
bishop is uh blocking the uh you cannot
capture the rookie spinning the bishop
you cannot capture with the King because
Bishop defends the rook and you cannot
go to G1 because the bishop covers the
G1 Square so that's not happening so
instead after Rook 8 to E3 Rook captures
and E3 was played but not just Queen
captures on E3 and again it's the same
threat only now with the queen how do
you defend against Queen captures on H3
nothing nothing really changed like it's
placed on like Bishop C1 you attack the
queen queen captures on H3 mating one
again all the same ideas so here King
the H1 was played by engage but now Rook
to F2 getting the queen away from the
defense of the H3 pawn and now it was in
this position animal 29 that Alexander
engines resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so truly a
a masterpiece by by Adams finding this
cool idea uh here we resign because
after he moved the queen just Bishop
captures on H3 we said that the the
queen was uh essential in the defense of
the H3 pawn and now uh pretty much
anything like you could go Rook to E1
you attack the queen now Bishop captures
and G2 check Queen captures and queen
capture Sunny one and even if the queen
blocks there are many cool moves here
like Rook to H do with check the queen
cannot capture because it's been you
have to capture with the King but now
again our good friend the bishop comes
to help out with with the checkmating of
the white king queen captures King H3
and Bishop to F2 now the white king gets
checkmated on the next move or if you
want to be a troll you can play Bishop
to E5 and prolong it for a move but I
mean we are not such people uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoy the
brilliant stuff with the black pieces
against an incredibly strong player like
uh like Alexander injich so I hope you
enjoyed that and hope it inspires you to
to go for greatness in your own games uh
I would like to thank Anthony Moore at
cheersdaily.com
Frank Brown III and Stefano Steinbach
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day